alors soit sert bienvenue à la 67e
cérémonie des golden directeur du hilton
ici elle m'appelle ricky gervais merci
et au savoir que c'est la dernière fois
que je présente cette cérémonie
complètement ça n'a jamais été le cas de
toute façon clairement rien à faire non
plus bon kevin hart a été viré des
oscars à cause d'un tweet qui a gêné
quelques percées regarder heureusement
pour moi la fft a pas un den anglais
savent pas du tout ce que c'est que
twitter dont combats pros on m'envoyait
ne comptera pas finir vraiment on va
coller à notre détriment sont que des
plaques en verre bientôt tous mourir il
n'y aura pas de suite peut même là
n'oubliez pas mais vous savez tous hier
les railhawks bien maquillage est
arrivée en limousine moi je suis arrivée
en limousine et s'est félicité hoffman
qui avaient préparé la laque
d'immatriculation c'est ça moi je suis
désolé pour sa fille ça doit être le
moment le plus gênant son frère était
dans le film célébrité ici ce soir des
légendes des icônes sur ses tables
seulement regarder al pacino robert de
niro
bybee yahouda bébé yoda non pardon c'est
joe pesci par le matador nom me fais pas
tu soignes s'agit que des gens qui sont
devant la caméra
là on a certains des plus grands spas
manager de la télé du cinéma dans cette
salle de nom de tous les partis ils ont
tout sauf une chose en commun ils sont
terrifiés par ronald farro il les autres
est aussi la vôtre mais en ôtant les
pervers et donc c'était une très grande
année une très grande allée pour les
films de pédaler sur valérie living
valentine's les deux papas fou de gens
de couleur de talent ont été snobés dans
beaucoup de catégories a rien à faire
les gens de la chef pierre sont tous
très très raciste et 100 m
c'est la cinquième fois oui oui on a les
catégories en mémoire des personnes qui
nous sont fixés mais bon quand je vois
les noms s'était passé divers aux morts
surtout des donc j'en suis libre non non
à part quand c'est moi qui présente son
prochain
la cwa on va voir ce qui va se passer
rien à faire du cinéma ociné on ne
regarde plus les grandes chaînes tout le
monde rit hier 9 flic il faudrait que
cette cérémonie a gagné non regardez
maintenant trois hommes mais pendant ce
temps là vous pourriez regarder toute la
première saison de l'acteur live au lieu
de regarder la cérémonie c'est qu'il
veut ce tuer le temps et lorsque sa
femme concerne et c'est encore plus
marrant que les
d'un globe ce pôle a amené la deuxième
saison quand il se suicide pas plus et
vous je sais que c'est votre ami mais je
m'en fous il faut s'en sortir mais bon
la plupart des films sont horribles sarr
et ceux des filets suite jean tabi une
tumeur s'il disait qu'il s'en va il y
avoir une suite au choix de sophie
mais bon ça serait mairie striby
deuxième bon alors celui là on fait quoi
tous les meilleurs sont assez générique
sièges pour les acteurs qui font des
films hollywoodiens maintenant font les
choses de fantaisie et aventure il n'est
pas très bien été question très simple
geste héroïque dans la salle de gym deux
fois quinze jours est-ce qu'on a un
[Musique]
imprimeur 16 l'actualité pour ses propos
polémiques sur les films de marvel à qui
il a dit que ce n'était pas du cinéma il
laisse alors les films n'est pas
d'attractions mais je sais ce qu'elle
fait dans les parcs d'attractions parce
qu'il n'a pas la taille nécessaire pour
aller sur granville cockpit ou près et à
richmond et dire oui mais c'était juste
incroyable
c'était super lent c'est le même crime
c'est elle et pour lui et il doit de ce
qu on entend presque trois superbes
couleurs de dicaprio est allée pierre et
à la fin du film est bien son regard de
la soirée avait pris trop d'âge pour lui
attention tu as presque 50 ans quand
même mon petit gars si james bond à
poussoirs james corden comme une
mauviette
il est aussi dans le film
na wan chose mais personne n'a dit ça y
est il écrit
j'en ai vu qui disait que c'était là
c'est la meilleure chose qui soit
arrivée au chant depuis les chiens font
disant que c'était le rôle pour lequel
elle était menée cette prochaine blague
sur la moquette lever la pâte et se
lécher la chatte
ouais enfin bon boule de poils cheese
house qu en face à l'ancienne
non c'est la dernière aussi lancé dans
les séries c'est chaud une série
dramatique magnifique abane série dans
ma dignité magnifique sur l'appétence de
l'humanité de faire signer préparer les
gens une entreprise qui reçoit des
petits enfants sinon entreprises pour
lesquelles vous travaillez vous
améliorez votre agent donc si vous
gagnez un prix ce soir ne l'utilisé pas
pour faire un discours politique vous
n'êtes pas bien placée pour donner des
leçons à la population là je vois que ce
soit les connaissez bien sûr et monde
réel jama exceptionnellement rené je
vais te dis prie à remercier votre agent
a bien dieu et barrez vous